Okay.
There is a renewed war against abortion and
there is a very specific reason why I told
you about this.
I told you that this would happen as soon
as Donald Trump got his first selection to
the Supreme Court and it was renewed even
more strongly.
As soon as Donald Trump got his second selection
to the Supreme Court.
Brett Kavanaugh, the religious right, the
social conservatives, the anti choice activists,
they have seized upon the reality and it is
a reality that they have a potential opportunity
here with this supreme court to undo decades
of progress on abortion rights, also known
as medical rights, also known as women rights,
women's rights, also known as legal medical
procedures.
And the reason that they've correctly identified
that this is an opportunity unlike one that
they've had in a long time, is that we now
have thanks to the election of Donald Trump,
one of the most conservative supreme courts
in a long time.
Now remember there were some people, I'm not
going to name names because that's not a productive,
but there were people who in 2015 and in 2016
in the lead up to the 2016 election were saying,
I don't care if it's Trump or Hillary.
Hillary is a centrist Democrat.
You might as well electron, but it's not going
to be any different.
Well, exhibit a as to why that's a laughably
absurd and malignantly ignorant is the supreme
court, which now will have an influence on
American political society, uh, and society
beyond just politics for decades, uh, is exhibit
a and the abortion battle, the renewed abortion
battle is one of the great examples of that
which gets us to, I mean, this is all just
contextualizing for you that we now have had
votes from the Alabama House of Representatives
and yesterday from the Alabama Senate approving
a measure to outlaw abortion in Alabama.
This would outlaw almost every abortion in
the state.
It would ban abortions at all points in time
in pregnancy.
It would criminalize doctors performing abortions
with felonies and up to 99 years in prison.
No exceptions for cases of rape, no exceptions
for cases of incest.
This is a dark ages law and it includes just
one exception for when the woman's life is
at risk.
So this is meant to be a direct challenge
to Roe v Wade at the supreme court level.
If things go the way they want.
Now you might say what, why, why is this happening
in Alabama?
Well, yes.
I mean Alabama is a more, uh, socially conservative
and religious state in the sense that they
want to punish gays and abortions, which are
popular, uh, priorities for the religious
right in the United States right now.
Uh, and of course it's happening in a state
that is a disaster.
I'm not insulting the people.
What I'm telling you is that Alabama has serious
problems to fix and what they're choosing
to do is to outlaw basically every abortion.
Um, the college graduation rate is extraordinarily
low in Alabama.
They are dead last, they are 50th in education
in Alabama.
They are 46th in healthcare.
They're economy is 45th out of 50.
In the United States, Opportunity is 45th
out of 50.
In the United States.
Crime is 45th out of 50th in the United States.
Infrastructure is 38th and so what do they
do?
They say let's ban all abortions.
So let's break it down one step at a time.
Is this bill likely to become the law?
Yes, sort of, but probably not immediately.
What I mean by that is, uh, that it's been
passed by the House of Representatives in
the house in Alabama.
It's been passed by the Senate.
It's believed that Alabama's governor Kay
Ivey, obviously a Republican is going to sign
it.
Although, uh, governor [inaudible] office
has not yet at least as of five minutes ago,
put out a statement one way or the other.
But there's the expectation that Kiv is going
to sign it.
So it sounds like it will become the law,
right?
Well, not so fast.
This is part of the longterm antiabortion
strategy.
More than likely if, and when the governor
signs this into law, there will immediately
immediately be a lawsuit filed demanding an
injunction.
And the idea here is to try to get that case
all the way up to the supreme court in order
to try to federally challenge abortion.
The way it will go is Kay Ivey signs it into
law.
It's immediately challenged in federal court,
uh, and more than likely, more than likely
because this is such an extreme piece of legislation,
the first court that will hear the appeal,
uh, may maybe likely block the law.
Okay.
A lot of legal experts are saying that first
court is likely to block the law and that's
the whole point of this.
For the anti choice activists who want to
have it blocked or expect it to be blocked
at the first court challenge, they will then
appeal the law ideally all the way up to the
supreme court.
At which point Brett Kavanaugh was a replacement
of centrists justice.
Anthony Kennedy could be the difference maker
in allowing a major precedent setting antiabortion
decision by the Supreme Court.
So I've got to hand it to them.
Okay.
I think these people are disgusting.
I think their priorities are backwards.
They are dead.
Last in education in Alabama.
They are, you know, I gave you the list already.
I, I truly find these to be despicable people
with all of the wrong priorities, but they're
pretty clever.
And they knew, I mean, when, when Mitch Mcconnell
participated in obstructing Barack Obama's
selection of Merrick Garland to the court,
that was step one of this longterm strategy.
And so we've got a praise the right, I mean,
we've got to recognize good strategy.
They were able to have a multi year plan.
Okay.
It was a year before the 2016 election and
Mcconnell starts with, well, we should really
let the voters have a say, uh, before we decide
who's going to be on the supreme court potentially
for decades that stretched into the 2016 election.
And then Trump, God, his replacement.
And then they negotiated a departure for Anthony
Kennedy under potentially nebulous circumstances.
And then incomes, Brett Kavanaugh.
And then they start with the state level stuff.
And I mean, they're, they're better than us.
They're better than us.
That's the reality.
We have to understand that they are better
than us and we're only going to do better
than them if we accept how good they actually
are and figure out how to fight against this
stuff.
So we'll see what happens.
The, this could be the beginning of significant
precedent setting abortion related rulings
by one of the most conservative supreme courts
in a long time, which if that happens, the
next part of the strategy is immediately that
Supreme Court decision, which may stem from
an appeal from this Alabama law or the one
recently, uh, moving forward in Georgia.
Then multiple states will pass similar laws
to this one and it would be a massive rollback
of abortion rights.
And if you're surprised by this, if you're
appalled by this, this is exactly what we
knew their plan was.
As soon as they realize that Donald Trump
had the opportunity of putting more conservative
justices on the supreme court.
And once again, it's already almost 20, 20.
If Trump wins, he likely will get at least
one more pic to the supreme court.
Yet.
Another reason we got to get rid of this guy
and we got to get rid of this guy right away.
Let me know what you think.
You can follow me on Instagram at David Dot
pacman.
Also follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David Pakman.
Show polls behind the scenes pictures, opportunities
for you to ask any questions
that great stuff.
We'll take a quick break.
Part two of my interview with the Great Cal
Newport is coming up next